we might be drunk
we might be drunk
as long as we are hanging out you know
we might be drunk raise a glass let's
talk [ __ ] head peeps wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk
we might be drunk
[Music]
hey we're here we're doing it folks
we're about to have a nice drink midday
we might be drunk this is it folks how
are you doing it man the day drinking's
it's starting to hurt
i'm not i was never a day drinker before
this podcast i was always like i called
it a night cap
oh yeah i like at the end of the night
it was kind of like helps you cruise
right in a bit i get a lot of like
nighttime hangovers now yes so do i
they're they're a [ __ ] they're a [ __ ]
we got to perform i know you got to
perform or you just need to go to i keep
drinking and then you're in that whole
boat well this helps the career this
ain't helping right here oh no but we're
doing it for you folks we're doing it
for you we're hurting ourselves for you
we hope you're enjoying it literally
yeah punishing our bodies for the for
the fans at home so uh get on board this
is like low-key jackass right here yeah
very low-key exactly
yeah i used to day drink a lot as a
youth same when you're young it's
different yeah and i was just an
alcoholic so i was just drinking that
was daydreaming and night drinking yeah
but yeah big i just love drinking the
sun in the sun i love it what's your
summer drink well i mean we would just
go get a case of natty ice yeah not
bragging awful they were like do
milwaukee's best i don't know why that
was a go-to but a lot of a lot of 40s
when you're a kid like oes oh yeah it's
something there was something fun about
holding a 40 too yes exactly you ever do
edward 40 hands i never did it but i've
seen it you'd make through a bottle cap
of beer i bet with your urinary tract
but uh yeah that was hard because you
had to drink them all you couldn't piss
until you and then one kid one of my
friends like i can't take it he smashed
a boat and then pulled his dick out
he got shards of glass in his hands
he's got him into the er circumcision
thank god yeah
uh but yeah yeah daydreaming there's
something about it that's like you ever
drink on a beach
i'm not a big beach guy ah i don't like
the beach i don't love it but
i'll do it once a year and i'll make a
meal out of it you know you get the mai
tai you got the fl floral board shorts
and the the white uh cream on the nose
and yeah really drink it up
the beaches in new york are terrible so
you didn't grow up with the beach either
no and they were right there that's
crazy they're not great because i had to
drive to florida it was five hours when
i was a kid yeah that's a lot oh yeah
but we would make a weekend i mean what
do you got brighton i've never even been
to bryden beach i kind of want to go
just to try the russian food i do go to
county island once a year yeah yeah but
it's for rides and you're a brooklyn guy
it was right there
nothing it's not close no no it's not
cool
yeah all right all right it's so weird
to take a train to a beach it is not
even a train a subway yeah
then you're vulnerable on the way back
because you got your shorts on the
flip-flops you're tan you're like burnt
it's not a good look you got your
umbrella and you got the duck around you
you know i'm park over beach
all right all right i know that's not
popular women we just every woman on
this [ __ ] podcast women love beaches
they love the beach what do you think
that is beach i think i'm used to it
no what do you think it is about a woman
that loves a beach
they want to get undressed they want to
be sun kissed they like the waves they
like it's romantic the park is not
really romantic the park is where you
get uh a jogger gets assaulted you know
it's not really there's a hobo [ __ ]
it's not one of my defenses people get
assaulted on the beach
no but i'm with you but there's
something about i don't know like you're
right it's the beach for women it's
almost like a bubble bath
if you're a man and you choose beach
over park it's kind of weird yeah and
park is great because there's no
commitment beach is like ah i'm gonna
get sun on my ass i'm gonna get sand in
my crack uh it takes forever to get
there the park is so close yet the beach
is sexy everything you just described
there's like sand in your crack your
feet are sandy but like baywatch there's
no park baywatch no
that's park watch we gotta shoot it
there's the peeping tom there's the rat
nest
you know is that a raccoon goddammit
sandy hook
that's when i pulled out of the sand but
yeah
we got to crack these
you said sandy i don't know
that's where my brain went
i donated there we go
that's the new that's the new uh i i
[ __ ] up a joke it's a new uh i gave
money to it that's the save line that's
a good one by the way what are these ice
cubes you got here this is not equal
opportunity you got the big nice round
one i got uh i got brad williams over
here you got ralphie mae
what the hell
this is just fresh right out of here
that's how you do it this is uh someone
sent us the the negroni craft cocktail
the bottle craft cocktails are making
hey man once our whiskey comes out
i say we do this but with an old pal
hey i like it i think we make the old
pal we do a push for that it's our drink
that's our drink i like it we make we
bring it back yeah i'll tell you paper
planes are taken off they're everywhere
now i hear the name paper planes around
yeah we really hijacked that one
unlike malaysia you know where it's
going
i don't know if that made sense
i donated
i don't call this one i donated
so where were you this weekend i was in
sacramento california seven shows i
didn't see that sold out seven shows i
love that room classic i i always i was
talking i had a couple great guys
opening joey avery and this guy dude
and uh he they had some good points they
said the best clubs are either in a red
state blue dot so like you're in the
liberal part of the like lexington
kentucky exactly perfect perfect example
um maybe philly yeah and in penn
sylvania so that oh that's like a
uh you know
you know it uh what's the word [ __ ] why
did i just go blank uh ohio florida also
swing state swing state yeah or like
even you know madison wisconsin right
perfect perfect example so those are fun
or
a town outside of
the big town
you know like la not not great to
headline but sacramento great to
headline l.a you don't think they're
going to show up exactly it's like you
sell out a show in la and it's like 60
of people show up and you're like we get
it i'm not the there's too much in your
mind to do what is that in l.a well
there's so many things to do and they
they're such celebrity
[ __ ] over there they're star [ __ ]
and we're not really stars so
there's not a lot of like i respect the
arts in la it's more like hey i've heard
of that guy
right
what do tourists do at night in l.a i
know like tourists here will go to
broadway or go to the improv or they'll
go on
you don't really do that in l.a what a
little bit well there's so many good
restaurants is that what it is yeah
there's a big restaurant culture in l.a
i mean whatever yes that well i don't
know about it at night but they do the
stars homes that's big that's [ __ ]
sad
what are you doing and talk about creepy
you know like hey you're looking into
bert lancaster's house you know
some old lady lives there now like get
out of here
it's like that's that's how they reboot
uh sunset boulevard it's some [ __ ]
weirdo who's looking at a star's home
yeah right then i got the walk of fame
yeah and you got man's chinese theater
mm-hmm you got the tar pits got a great
chinese town chinatown is great mexican
food great what are the nighttime
activities i'm always at a friend all i
do is like yeah i feel like they have
bigger homes there than we do we don't
have people over in new york good point
i mean in la you you go to each other's
houses i think they can go clubbing they
go clubbing
you know it's like this is ashton
kutcher's club you know it's like
there's like a hot club every 10 minutes
what a horrible can you imagine we're
going cl i mean i remember the last
couple years i did [ __ ] like that yeah i
was like what am i what am i doing even
as a youth i hated it same same give me
a dive bar as bill hicks would say under
a beer light i look pretty cool you know
well i'm not gonna do it with like a
stare i might do it i might win you over
with like a joke or some [ __ ] i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna go home with a woman
based on being like
totally or dance moves
at the club it doesn't work everybody's
doing blow in the bathroom it's so loud
the bottle service yeah you feel like
you can't afford anything i hate clothes
you see people waiting in that line in
the winter
you should be in a mental hospital yes
you deserve to be put away like if
you're there for more there should be a
timer if you're there for more than 20
minutes and it's 20 degrees or lower
just swoop them up toss them in a van
they're never to be heard from again
that's shutter island too right there
agreed and i have these people have geds
i'm like you can stand out here in a
[ __ ] mini skirt in 12 degree weather
go to school
this is very good this strong yeah do
you want to try it yeah it's got a kick
and uh this is a what's it called ben a
what's the brand we should give this a
shout out i think it's uh homeschool
negroni made with small batch
ben a i don't know what's the actual
brand name is chill on ice bounce round
negroni is one of the best cocktails oh
yeah you can't do much better than a
negroni you know what's in it uh sweet
vermouth campari and gin nice
there you go i love i make them at home
a lot i mean we were we did ahri's
podcast uh recently and
he had the monkey 47 gin that [ __ ] is
it's super expensive but it's incredible
yeah i've never actually bought a bottle
but i i've been around a lot of people
who do
yep it's very nice very finer things
type of guy
you know what he's specific here's ari i
went to his house i showed up before you
he's got a record player going with the
who on the blower which was cool and
then he was making coffee in one of
those uh beakers so you're like you're
that guy you know he's swirling it and
it goes in the funnel hipster he's a
hipster that's exactly what he's he's
like he's a hipster doofus he's kramer
but kramer's act is better
just a later face kramer was called the
amazing racist too
[Laughter]
yeah he took the title
[Laughter]
um
sacramento and that's such a weird club
because it's a great room but you're
right next to a mattress shop i know and
you know they've heard it all like oh
i'm performing next to a mattress shop
totally totally i i had to make that
joke as well and uh it's just a cute
sleepy california town yeah uh we played
ping pong all day like uh one of the
features he's like oh my friend lives
here we're gonna go meet him have lunch
and play ping-pong at his house you go
there the bike's on the front lawn the
door's unlocked it's a cute neighborhood
we play ping-pong in his shed it's just
so california living and i checked the
news snowstorm in new york everybody's
bunkered down it's ruined and the hobos
are frozen outside they're holding their
dicks how weird was that so we i got the
same reports obviously i'm in baltimore
in my show it's cold but it wasn't that
i mean yeah took a walk on the on the
water with my uncle and you're like oh
this is [ __ ] cold oh wow but what
were you doing a mob hit what were you
guys
i couldn't have any uh
i was like all right just tell me what
you need
i uh no we did that and of course you
know it snowed a little bit there but
new york i'm watching like christa
stefano sell volcano adrian i palute
they're all like my show's cancelled and
and people are messaging me
is your show still happening i'm like
looking around like yeah
it's happening yeah right but there's
some kind of community love with the new
york snow i feel like the city comes
together there's always that video of
the one guy skiing on broadway you know
there's something about it i love it
it's great it's great the whole city
comes together the after effects are sad
though and it's just like the icing
everywhere it is like it does have the
feel of a hangover the slush this is for
sure it's dirty
it's gross you gotta throw these on oh i
got the boots on yeah this is our first
boot episode yeah we're getting booted
yeah that was that was that was the uh
the term getting thrown out of a bar the
boot get the boot that was a bar in uh
in new orleans yes pull up the boat it's
weird to be called it's weird to
call the place the worst case scenario
well i think it was based on it used to
be a country bar so it was like the boot
like big cowboy boot but they had nickel
shot night they had quarter beer night
yeah i mean i would i got oh you can
drink i think it was like five bucks all
you can drink yes and bush is like
college kids dude this is a [ __ ] mess
it's amazing and it's literally across
the street from tulane literally across
the street and that's it yeah i mean
i've spent so many nights there great
pete dino's pizza big pizza like a slice
this big look at that crawfish fridays
come on this is bringing me right back
home
yeah i got thrown out of there once
because i was 17 and all my friends were
18. so they went and they were like you
got to get in i'm like i can't even get
in at 18. but back yeah back then you
could you could get in i don't know if
you could drink what a weird thing to be
allowed into a bar
but you can't drink maybe no i think so
i mean some places must do that right
yeah maybe but maybe i was 20 or
something i couldn't get in either way i
was one year short
and
i found a wristband it was all about
wristbands back then i found a wristband
on the ground it was stepped on peed on
i picked it up i
blew it off just like livestrong
i put it on with some gum literally gum
and i you know clamped it together and i
walk in the guy goes you got your
wristband i go come on what am i a
[ __ ] newbie i got you and it
literally fell off as i lifted it up oh
no and the guy grabbed me
slammed me against the wall and then
threw me out and it was so embarrassing
and it hurt my nose was bleeding and i
was on the sidewalk like
all right i'm cool i'm okay and then i
just had to wait for my friends damn
good times good time new orleans is
amazing oh yeah you just did a show
there recently right i did the howlin
wolf yeah my parents came out it was how
big a venue it's like i don't know 400
seats why don't you go bigger though you
could probably sell it a huge venue
there ah we did two of them they gave us
a good deal and it's the first place i
ever did comedy so it was like some kind
of sentimental [ __ ] sweet yeah but
it was it was so new orleans the first
show was amazing it was like the best
night of my life i got my mom a standing
o and then the second show was like you
suck remember in high school when you
got a pants you [ __ ]
it is good every once in a while yeah i
mean i was really starting at tulane
when i did comedy i remember bill burr
was like i i kind of weaseled my way in
to the uh you know i was like i'm a
comic i had like a bringer tape from
caroline's you know it might have been a
vhs that's how long ago maybe it was a
dvd and i remember
i was like can i just open for whoever
you bring and they said uh it's that fan
i was like please i'll do anything yeah
500
theater
i went up and i had a great set i killed
they were like mediocre college jokes
it's like you know when you're with your
guys at a bar they're all dumb jokes but
yeah they hit and and i think when they
said this guy's a two-lane student
everyone like was like they actually
were pretty cheering me on hell yeah and
uh then the people who booked the comics
were like you can help book the comics
so they're like who should come down
huge and i remember i said bring bill
bird down wow and they brought him down
i got to open for him and what year are
we talking i was probably 19. but so
what 19 2006. so even at 2006's bill
burr was not i thought he was great he
had already done the philly rant i had
already oh he had okay i'd seen him at
the comic strip i thought he was such a
great comic what a purist you could have
brought any big hot shot and get david
brenner out here it was it was weird
because you know it was like a big huge
theater probably 1200 cedar bill wasn't
as big as he is now yeah and i'd say
like a hundred people showed up and and
they were scattered he kept making jokes
about it and he made it hilarious
he was so nice i remember it was like
the week
that forgot what's the name of the
yankee reliever who
flew a helicopter into that building in
midtown yes
but i remember uh it was like the day it
was maybe the day or the day after that
happened and bill's like did he hear
about that and i was like yeah but
you're a red sox fan right and he goes
not that big a red sox man
wow
if i was bill everybody
there it is corey corey title yeah good
player
if i was bill i would be forever
indebted to you like yeah you brought me
down to that college
to him what are you talking about i
don't know but now you're uh like the
you know now you're a real estate you
know it's crazy we were on conan
together i think it was like 10 years
later we were on conan together that's
wild and he was he didn't remember
obviously but uh what that would be my
friend hey remember tulane i got you i
don't i mean i'm sure he was doing gigs
he was working think about think about
how many comics you work with
yeah he gave me like i think i remember
that but i was like i don't i think he
was being polite sure we do so many gigs
and you get drunk
look at this doesn't uh burr fly
helicopters oh
don't even put that [ __ ] energy into
the world connection don't even put that
energy into the world
my uncle flies helicopters too i was in
baltimore and he's like one of those
like just does everything guys he's a
doctor at johns hopkins he flies a
helicopter your family is very
impressive by the way i know it's
[ __ ] brutal i am really rough for you
i know giraffe because i'm like you know
he's on tv yeah i'm on tv but
you try sitting at that dinner table
he had a wgn show
msg
wgn would have maybe been bigger i think
i think that's multi-state oh
msg is tri-state yeah
yeah what are you gonna do tried hard i
saw i went to a two-lane show because i
was like getting into comedy it was in
the like uh it was in the quad it was
like 20 seats i remember it was finnegan
christian finnegan wow joe derosa and
chuck nice i think it was
derosa uh we might be drunk alum
yeah exactly i should have told him that
when he was here i forgot but i remember
i only remember his joke about being
adopted everything else everybody's
great ever but yeah that stuck with me
what was the joke he said uh you know uh
people always asking when when you say
your adopted did you ever try to find
your real parents and i said uh no you
know i took the hint actually
that's a great joke great joke and i saw
that no seven or whatever that was yeah
i opened for tal alexandra as well there
another great one another great one he
was awesome he had a great opening line
it was a year after katrina it was right
after katrina and he goes uh ever since
i uh this is opening like crushed ever
since i heard what happened with the
hurricane i i've been dying to get down
here no whatever it takes i'll get down
here and then he pause he goes it's been
a year now
huge pop he had that great joke too he's
like what's up with these natural
disasters i can't it's like mudslides
hurricanes that's another one
oh oh yeah much but the hurricanes
is this a natural disaster or this is
the tgi friday drink menu and you're
like oh how do we all miss that that's
great hurricane mudslide there's another
one yeah car bomb i can't remember
something like that yeah i saw that
you're playing the deep south i saw it
on your instagram you posted alabama
alabama yeah you posted uh something
saying you're looking for someone to
shoot 4k for you yeah yeah yeah or like
no one down there
[Laughter]
on your line
you can do it 3k did we lose that yeah
that's pretty good
hold on i'm going to reset and reset it
hey madam reset the jokes oh we can't
redo it
ah i thought you were setting me up i am
oh
well now we have to lose it peter all
right all right
so i i hear they're uh you're looking
for somebody
because you get you're laughing all
right all right too soon
so i hear you're playing the deep south
alabama
and i saw on your ig
you posted you're looking for someone to
shoot 4k video yeah i don't think they
really do that down there yeah they do
k's there it is all right
thanks guys
comedy
uh
he has to get his [ __ ] catchphrasing
this is his getter done he can't he
can't just tell a joke anymore he's
gotta he's gonna push merch well i see
people in the front row of my shows in a
comedy shirt
i have a joke about wearing your belief
on your shirt and mid joke a guy points
to his shirt and i was like i see you
that's great i see it dude
all right keep wearing that merch
but yeah i'm getting my ass kicked that
show is because i'm like i do the
dramatic pause to set up a punchline and
someone [ __ ] goes comedy right in the
middle of it the silence and i'm like
you're killing me man i know you're
trying to be supportive but you're
that's true
they want a moment i know and they wait
they snipe right in that silence another
great alexandro joke yeah is not an
album or anything i remember we did a
show the day that uh farrah fawcett and
michael jackson died and ted opened a
show goes man what a day and and people
were like shaq to the cavs can you
believe it
god he's good great mister such a pro
yeah ted alexandro if you don't know him
you should he's got like six specials in
a couple half hours he's out there folks
you can find him give him a goog
yeah we love you you had good taste back
then even you knew the guys well you did
too didn't you not like i don't know as
well as you i was definitely deceived by
hacks too i mean there were like there
were comics i knew were great like ted
and bill but um
i remember i brought up ted or bill
bursted like who else came down here and
i said alexander and he goes oh he's a
great comic oh oh wow so it was nice
that they all you know were in that
world back then but uh
no i was seduced by hacks like anyone is
i remember seeing comics like you know
walk a room and being like whoa rock and
roll meanwhile you're like no the point
is to entertain people yeah not to burn
a whole that's a last resort right right
completely but you i feel like living in
new york you saw dave patel at
caroline's we're super young i only knew
david tell as a new orleanian from
insomniac
so i was you know uh restricted a little
bit to tv you were the guy from night
court right harry anderson yeah yeah he
was a new orleans guy yeah he lived
there and i think he eventually died but
he was away he was such a bad drunk he
had a bar in the corridor but uh he
would wake up on people's lives
like it was like a cool oh man the guy
from night court loves the world how
great is that like a couple celebrities
fall in love with new orleans and never
leave like john goodman bought a house
and
brad pitt bought a house but harry
anderson went all in bought a bar crazy
drunk and he became like the town
nuisance
that's the show that's the show that's
the show he's got a guy like harry
here's the show you know how you fell
down the other night
we're thinking three cameras cbs what do
you say
yes exactly i'm sure he ended up at
night court wow brian dennehy
have you ever seen harry anderson's
magic
no i heard he's amazing he's amazing do
you want to watch it yeah let's see
can we are we allowed to show this
peters hold on hold on pause it i feel
like every every podcast is showing this
clip
you know this is hack now
[Applause]
look at that dress like a 40s gangster
yeah what is this the big heat what the
hell oh he's like a swing guy
like my suit
huh see ya that's new
yeah it was just like if rick moranis
we're gonna rip you off my wife
you know i mean jackets big but it came
with a wallet
but that's small talk and we're here to
do a money trick
i love money tricks
good
money
this was tv so much dead air
at a different time can you imagine like
trying to pull this off today
get it back come on cut it out
saturday night rip off
lady you got a purse you got money give
her a hand a big hand give her a hand
she's like just our show on the road now
yeah right
hi
watch him dazzle us in the next minute
though
turn around judy i'm harry but then
aren't we all really
judy uh you got a bill it's cute
bill any kind of bill will do
and i have a red dependent
what you got there
five five will do okay take this judy
lady this was she was the biggest gal in
town for 10 minutes after this everybody
will recognize the bill if they ever see
it again
you got one all right give me the bill
you can get the pen that's how i got it
here we go
okay we got a bill with uh
a big red x on it he tore in half oh
that's right people are just listening
to this yeah yeah oh boy trying to fill
it in
oh i thought people want i mean a lot of
people watch right yeah yeah wait he put
the bill back together i skipped ahead
because i felt bad for all the people
you can't bring up a magic clip and then
skip around we have to follow the trick
man
all right man
nice job google [ __ ]
this is like a dana carvey character on
snl oh i know the sloan is a lot of
people watch this right right what's the
percentage of people that watch this
what
i'm not good at oh
[Laughter]
he's folding the bill that was torn in a
bunch he just yells out the jews will
not replace us like oh my god clean as a
whistle
all right this is a basic trick though i
mean yeah it's a street trick i guess i
thought if you mixed it with comedy or
something all right is this snl yeah wow
that's on saturday night live i haven't
gotten much better
sorry guys yeah it'd be hilarious if he
was just slamming like the hot chick of
his day oh i'm sure he had a couple of
brodies he wasn't banging the kim
kardashian of his death no no he wasn't
pete dave no
what harry anderson dating cousin that's
the first thing that came up really well
louisiana
his first trick was i is this your birth
certificate
let's get rid of that yeah
wow harry anderson r.i.p alright the bar
is still there
harry's bar it's still there
we haven't given him a hell of a pitch
we pull up his magic and we're like
anyway he's got a bar i remember andy
dick was in the news i don't know two
years ago before covet he went to
harry's bar got drunk made out with a
guy the guy wasn't looking for it then
he punched danny dick and annie dick
went to jail i don't know like tuesday
like every day
this is my impression of andy dick's
publicist
is it ever good
news i know right you ever lose your
[ __ ] keys
no
is it ever an appearance in a show where
you just do well right don't lick
someone's face yeah what happened to
news radio remember we had a good run
that was a good show good show pull up
the andy dick uh i think tmz covered it
but i just want to be
i want to be a
made hole here it's just andy dick drunk
in a bar someone give me a dollar
not for a marker i need a dollar really
badly yeah
yeah i always wonder how these guys have
money how do they pay the bills you know
he did a lot of he did a lot of stuff i
guess the residuals
yeah that's new orleans i don't know
what street that is maybe royal or geez
who knows too loose
is this the camera
oh it just got walloped
oh
the guy dropped him
yeah you can't [ __ ] around out there
that's a [ __ ] dude that's not yeah
that's not cool no no and any dick's a
bit of a twink that's that's that's a
hate crime that's [ __ ] up
yeah and that's a big dude with a sucker
punch on andy dick [ __ ] yeah watch this
here comes a haymaker bam
oh he went downhill good news is he
didn't feel it yeah that's true he's a
[ __ ] star like arya's though poor guy
yeah yeah he's a rabble rouser i think
he's got stuff going on though too yeah
very funny guy i mean great comedic
actor the [ __ ] scene in old school oh
my god he killed that yeah what a great
move todd phillips todd phillips
todd i heard you're making joker two
here's my pitch for joker two joaquin
just walks into a comedy club and then
watches me do an hour special
joker two what do you think that's not
bad
i like it and then at the end he's like
you know what i'm gonna give comedy
another shot joker three perfectly set
up
beautiful
oh wow look at this
that haircut is perfect
we got the same hair as jillian anderson
from
[ __ ] x-files yeah who's the the girl
in the red she was she was a smoke show
okay we all have to show this peters
i don't think so
okay oh we got the other yeah this is a
podcast we shouldn't be doing too many
clips sean murphy has a great bit about
how women take blow job classes like
that just shows how nice how much nicer
women are than men i don't know any guy
who's like i'm going to an eating eating
clam class you know a bunch of guys with
oysters
wow that's a great bit
damn
that's funny man
yeah he's good check out sean murphy
he's around
he's got another i think he's got an
album out called neil yeah give him a
real plug
he's around he's not fun
i don't know what to say he's around
sean with an
s-h-a-w-n the real irish
sean
but yeah
yeah sacramento though killer just one
of those magic weekends every show was
great sold out of merch uh great openers
hot hot shows got a little work done too
good times
yeah i was at mcgoobies in uh baltimore
it's timonium but you know stayed in
baltimore great man i had a weird thing
happen to me oh please in the hotel i'm
in the hotel room
and it's late night baltimore you're
hearing gunshots i'm like
you know baltimore's still baltimore
like i'm in a nice area but like six
blocks down you're like this is kind of
shady still right it's on brand and uh i
mean that's what you want when you go to
the baltimore right you want to hear a
few gunshots yeah
but uh i i'm in the room it's like 2 a.m
my hotel phone rings never a good sign
wow never good anyone who needs to reach
me they've got my cell yeah yeah that's
so true we're good when the phone rings
i'm like what at 2 am i pick up i go
what i'm angry 2 a.m
i'm up but i'm i'm like why are you
calling me you know yeah yeah and the
guy goes oh uh wrong number oh
shady chasing the joint for chicks maybe
feel shady feel shady guess what happens
10 minutes later
my room door opens with a key someone
out of here
i got my deadbolt on i got my double
down because i'm not a rookie and that
noise is no joke that clunk with the
deadbolt oh i'm [ __ ] angry yeah i'm
angry i'm i go what what the [ __ ] i'm
screaming i'm angry
and the guy goes oh my mistake and i
call the front desk what the [ __ ] dude
you gave a guy my room key and the guy
goes it was a mistake sir
no no no no i made a mistake i go is
this some sort of [ __ ] robber you're
trying to pull on me uh-huh i said do
you think there's some [ __ ] do you
think i'm some like rookie
this is like this is a robbery set up
they know you're in town
maybe have cash on you working a [ __ ] i
don't think i don't think it's that i
think there's like so but that's where
my mind's going very paranoid you know
new yorkers i don't get paid in cash
that's not what's happening i'm not
[ __ ]
i'm not kat williams i think we talked
about that i'm not getting a suitcase
after my show or in my case an envelope
but uh
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
what
but uh but i was this close to going
with mason just spraying saying get
something [ __ ]
um
that's why i'm a knight but get the
[ __ ] knife away man
[Music]
the hawaiian shirt with a knife doesn't
work yeah who are you crocodile dundee
i know
apparently yeah
you should be a knife guy too i'm not a
knife again 2 am knock on the door no
the maze is better than the knife i like
throwing star yeah i keep one in my boot
but wait so i have nunchuck
so the guy the guy's a dick at the front
desk i'm like hey man i get it like i'm
going to say this in my head i'm like i
get it like it's a [ __ ] job it's it's
late at night no one wants a night shift
at a hotel in baltimore graveyard no one
wants that [ __ ] i get it like i work at
night and i i like my life i can't
imagine if i didn't like my job you know
what i mean that's a tough it's a tough
gig so
the next day
i kind of you know i i'm pissed but i
bring you know i bring it up to the guy
the nxt next day the guy could have been
nicer they comp the night at the hotel
they couldn't have been cooler but uh
same guy different guy different guy
that guy that night was like he was like
it happens dude that's why they put him
on at 2am i hate to say it because he's
got an attitude you can't put that guy
on during the day yeah he'll get some
karen up his ass and just you know light
him up yeah
well [ __ ] but the shows were killer jp
mcdade opened crushed great jokes and uh
great shows man just like i i had a
great time what's the most charitable
excuse for this guy's behavior what is
could have gone on that they claimed the
guy had a similar name checking in to me
but to me that's like
okay but you know i'm in that room so
you're just giving they called up
minutes earlier
yeah the call up is weird
sorry i think it's birth control
i don't like that call up this is and
this is a nice place that was nice
i wonder if he's in cahoots
yeah yeah i don't know i don't like it i
don't know my guess is he was trying to
sell a room on the download to someone
else like but what's it called
i think it was a mistake
it was just i think it was a shady
mistake is what i think and i think he
was just like i'm not paying attention
interesting but i don't get how you have
a guy's checking in with a similar name
to me and you just give him like well
you see the room is taken yeah exactly
shady i don't do the deadbolt now i will
after hearing the story you don't do the
dead i never even think about it you've
never heard a guy walking on you jacking
off
no i leave it open
no i've never had that yeah i mean i
mean it's one thing when you pay for it
but when it's unexpected i've had the
lady go hello housekeeping i'm like no
thank you no thank you you like wait
keep saying housekeeping
just keep the door closed but keep
saying it and then she'll come in and
i'll throw the covers on and i'm like ah
rape
exactly but i've never had the uh that's
what the
watch i don't know how to turn it off i
don't know how to i said it once on
accident i can't fix it it's a time mix
do you say you say on action instead of
by accident oh yeah what do you say well
it's on purpose and by accident all
right
well you say on purpose on accident
you don't want to go by accident because
it's not by purpose
i did that by accident
i did that on purpose
yeah
what uh
what peeves you got going on oh
oh [ __ ] hold on let me pull up the old
people get some [ __ ] peeves dude hit
me with one while i will i get mine
ready i wrote so many down i've got too
many this week oh please i'm just like
because of this pod now i write him down
that's what you got to do
you know what peeving me and this is
this might be too inside baseball
the guy who hits you up going uh you get
the dm or the email from rando and it's
like hey man are you available on april
3rd
and i'm like for what well that you
don't answer that you're too successful
to answer that oh i always go yeah sure
but then he's like well we got a
three-ring circus we need an opener
there's eight people it's in uh it's in
wuhan and i'm like what ah [ __ ] how much
does it pay
but it's 40 flight not included yeah and
you need to clean up horse [ __ ] after
the show people think if you're
available you're just like i'm in but
i'm like what what you gotta give me
information don't just ask if i'm
available ask if i'm available for this
particular gig with this amount of money
it's even that for me that doesn't
bother me it bothers me when it's like a
friend
because you don't have to do that sure
when it's a friend they're like tom
mccaffrey used to have a great bit about
their like uh what are you doing
wednesday and you're like uh
i need some help moving you're like oh i
actually have a doctor's appointment
wednesday and like oh [ __ ] i'm wrong it
was actually thursday and tom's turn was
uh he goes the doctor just told me to
come in whenever you have to move
man
but
dude
yeah it makes me the the asking for the
availability before the thing
lead with a good thing i mean that
should only be done if it's a really
good thing yes what are you doing
wednesday night what's up nick's tickets
that's the only time it should never be
a favor that way that's a [ __ ] that's
trickery that's trickery yeah so i'm
just sitting there like am i available i
am but am i being dishonest if i'm like
ah no what the hell but then now i go
for what
and then put it on them but it's it's a
[ __ ] of a move are you available it's a
[ __ ] it's it's the bait and switch of
people i know because then if they go
are you available and i go uh for what
oh i got a gig for you and i go
well how much money is it then i go geez
oh i thought you were an artist you got
an agent do you have like a power agent
how am i doing with this [ __ ] i gotta go
on to the table answering facebook
messages at 2am about gigs in [ __ ]
singapore hey i went to philly last week
i'll go to jersey i'll go upstate i'll
i'll i'll go behind the agent's back all
day long
you're saying this on your podcast
your reps listen to this i'm sure oh
yeah they do well i mean it's like 250
bucks here 500 there i mean this is this
is these are all lies mark is making
much more money than this
peanuts but i'm just saying hey look we
got our lives to live too what are we
gonna just suck at the teat of uh
william morris all all our lives come on
we gotta mix it up
matt we have more stuff to cut oh no
no the hell are you doing mark sorry
sorry this negroni is getting me right
back
you did seven shows in sacramento you're
doing 200 gigs on the in this makes no
sense well sometimes the guy go hey i
got 38 people who are willing to watch
you i'll give you 200 bucks you can do a
workout show it's a workout show so i
couldn't i could work it out he just
taped something i i hear that that makes
sense i'm dying for new material i'm
floundering here yeah so
yeah it's just fun you go to some saloon
in uh albany nah that's too far but you
go to some saloon and wherever and you
drive back that night it's pretty great
remember phantom power oh i did it twice
during the pandemic there you go did you
tell your agent yeah ah they brought it
to me oh really yeah oh geez mine never
heard of phantom they booked me every
week what am i gonna like they're gonna
get me more money than if i did it well
good point okay maybe i'll do it that
way
you've got a power agency behind you and
you're doing your own negotiating well
they got there they'll give me seven
shows of the sack punch line but then
this is you know
i don't want to give them 20 percent
you do oh because you have a manager too
and an agent
yeah i've never haven't had a manager in
years
they don't do [ __ ]
they really don't well mine's pretty
good and i'm i'm a i'm an idiot when it
comes to i'll i had a a philly amtrak
and i booked it myself i felt so proud
of myself i patted myself on the back i
gave myself a gold star i get to the
amtrak at 6 00 p.m
the the trains at 6 30. i booked a.m
so i had to like pay a bunch of money to
get it and i lost my whole profit margin
damn go inside baseball a little bit
what is a manager for specifically what
does your manager do for you
organization mostly like the itinerary
they get the hotel [ __ ] going they get
the flights they get it all going but my
manager is more annoying than anything
how'd you get on a 10 a.m train then
shouldn't your manager fix that
because i booked it i was being shady
karma man i guess so well you know uh
the booking the flights i used to
imagine you then like i'm paying you 10
to book flights like you're still
running the options by me i can just
book the flight and then uh make sense
for booking hotels like
i don't know my agents i they do all
that i don't see the value in a manager
i don't i don't get like
i i'd much rather spend money on
people editing together clips or [ __ ]
like that sure
but you do have a good manager i think
most of them are
you know whatever i think my managers
have gotten me stuff i wouldn't have
gotten without well that's different
that's different that's what i'm saying
so
it's case by case
sure but an agent is really the one who
gets you gigs
finds stuff
sets it up hey you got to do this
weekend hey we got you hbo whatever my
agents do a lot for me i i'm i got a
great agent yeah they they're great
you're doing the beacon because your
agent believed in you which is huge well
uh i gotta pee for you all right please
see a doctor
about you know my neck i have you know
these neck problems these herniated
discs osteoarthritis all this [ __ ]
in my neck
and uh i'm seeing a guy and he doesn't
speak great english
and the lack i have no problem if you
don't speak great english i know you
still probably know what you're doing
but the way he's saying [ __ ] is making
me more anxious
like he's like you have neck disease
i have a disease in my neck he's like no
not disease i'm like well you said that
yeah he's like what is the word i'm
looking for i'm like you're the
doctor this is a bit this is crazy
he's a medical professional you can't
get the words right
they passed the medical hold on let me
get out of the thesaurus for you doctor
yeah what the hell this ain't uber
driver this is a doctor
i had a bad haircut because a guy had a
language barrier and uh that was i was i
cried over that you don't want that on
your kidney yeah yeah exactly exactly
damn that's bad yeah and look at me out
foreigners are great doctors you know i
walk in i see an indian guy go thank god
or a chinese guy people talk about
racism working uh positively positive
races right
yeah you're like
but it's still kind of weird for an
indian guy to walk in you go yes
thank god well how do you think the high
school basketball coach feels like oh
the black guy showed up thank god we're
in we're gonna make the playoffs there's
a story charles barkley told about larry
bird
cursing he talked a lot of [ __ ] and he's
cursing and barkley's like what the hell
man he goes you're disrespecting me
putting the white player on me larry
bird said that oh
wait larry bird said that to barkley
yeah cause this i guess it was the
sixers of the suns they were playing
each other and uh
whatever team barkley was on at the time
when he go i think was the sixers and he
goes why are you putting a white
defender on me oh bird was pissed being
like that's disrespect celtics yeah okay
he's a little disrespectful yeah
but he's a hell of a player well that's
the point he's like i'm great why is it
why don't you put a black player on me
that was larry bird wow pretty funny and
larry bird i mean
legend oh man hideous man not a handsome
man no bad look kind of looks like an
ostrich yeah he does he's a bird he's a
bird so good
he's got to be irish oh yeah i mean
that's like a if you're a boston sports
fan that's like the dream you're like a
blonde irish white guy and he's hurt for
boston it's like the white hope
for sure yeah what what what is he six
eight you think six ten wow
he was a [ __ ] phenom man
he's
from french lick indiana and he'll talk
[ __ ] to anybody he's a hoosier yeah how
about that oh dude he was ridiculous
ambidextrous look at these
[Music]
man great shooter do we have another
great honky out there in the on the
court right now yeah well steve nash was
great oh yeah he's a great white player
right now i'm trying to think there are
there are but i can't think off the top
of my head right now yeah i mean
nowitzki oh dirk was incredible yeah
yeah there's fun yeah luka doncic is
great yeah but i want an american yeah
i'm trying to think of an american white
guy
yeah we got tom brady on the on the
gridiron but well there's a lot of white
quarterbacks that's true you have to
look at this pass real quick i have
never seen anything like this two white
quarterbacks in the super bowl
that's right you know he was an insane
pastor people compare him to like you
know to lebron or lebron to him rather
but uh i got i got a bunch of peeves
dude oh maybe another one i mean it
light it up yeah leave me
see what else i got i had i had another
one in my head and i lost it
ah
oh
guy nearly walks into me on the street
because he's crossing the street today
reading
not looking at his phone oh yeah reading
a book
that's the time to read a [ __ ]
novella uh at an intersection what the
hell are you doing at least be up to
date rude yeah you're reading a [ __ ]
get a kindle exactly or a phone
well yeah that's what that's when an
audiobook is for when you're walking you
don't you don't just do the book
yeah while you're walking because
texting you can only do with a phone so
i get it it's still rude but i get it
but the book come on maybe at the
funeral though they can say he died
doing he loved he loved reading yeah i
guess so yeah he's also amish apparently
come on yeah
the walking and reading i'm with you i
got another one for you people who
keep hitting the same button on the
elevator you're not doing anything
that's so true and
and you're just like
if the button's pressed dude you're
right if it's door closed you can press
it once but
like it's not the clitoris dude take a
break
it's so true and the elevator is the
last bastion maybe flights but the elbow
is the last passion of like i have to be
with other people
they get off the floor before me i just
have to wait because everything is so uh
what's the word
care uh
now what's the
cultivated no curated curated for us we
take our uber we got our facebook we got
our pro uh profile
the elevator's like
people get on they get off that's it
small public space yes
everything everything's kind of very
personalized now like this is how i do
it get away from me i got ubereats
coming you know i got my order i'm
gluten free i'm this and that the
elevator is the last bastion of like
this is all public anybody can get on
and anybody can go on any floor they
want and hold you up and that's just how
it goes
yeah for sure there's something too but
you're right ubers dude i had a cab
driver talk to me the other night and i
was like oh [ __ ] that's what we used to
do yes you forget about that right
exactly and i'd rather talk to a cabbie
than an uber driver any day of the
weekend an uber driver is like you ever
take an la uber driver and they're just
like will you read a scene with me and
you're like what are you out of your
[ __ ] mind
i want to hear you complain about the i
want to hear you i want your cabbies are
the best every every sentence they say
is like a [ __ ] uh new york post
headline yeah they're like den of
thieves and you're like what was that
hell yeah bozo and queen
yeah i think that's a mullany joke but
yeah i love uh i had a great new york
cab drive at the other you know and
we've talked about in this pod before
i'm gonna i go yellow cab over uber if i
can help it every time because you know
it's just it's more new york i love the
yellow cab it's quicker the rhythm of
the city the city is not meant to be
like waiting yes for 10 10 minutes it's
like a wave you catch it you can't it's
a it's the energy you you don't even
stop walking i love it i love
the look of it i love
and and they got done dirty by you know
they weren't protected by the city and
like that's part of the city they should
have protected new york i know and now
they're all gone and when you need one
you notice it you're like damn i used to
be able to get a cab any day of the week
any time of the day and now it's like
catches catch can with a cab yeah you
mean you could watch the show taxi and
enjoy it but just know that judd hirsch
and all those characters when they grew
up and they got older that that
medallion wasn't worth [ __ ]
that's a sad ending to that show if you
think about it totally these guys would
move here from all over the place and
just be like uh i got the medallion and
now it's worthless i wasted my whole
life getting this medallion
[ __ ] man yeah they should have done
more but uh but you're so right but you
ever get into an uber pool you're like
this is not not in a while but yeah i've
done a bunch back in the day that's one
of the let's like an elevator where
you're like i don't know you you don't
know me and you're like oh we used to be
more communal we used to be talking to
strangers more and hanging out more and
interacting more and now everything is
so
uh
just
personal this is mine this is yours i've
talked to guys who like hook up in uber
pools
i'm like that's almost like not cool
that's almost like a hostage situation
they're just like yeah i talked to a
woman and we hit it off in the thing and
i'm just like
jesus i mean like i would never have the
balls to be gaining pool to make a show
that's not bad ben bailey he drags the
camera
no but there's uh there's something
about it uh
yeah yeah that is there is a show though
man that's good
that's like tax cab confessions in a way
the woman in the car next you just drop
them off pick up another guy
i had a there was an lsu louisiana state
university there was a drunk bus because
they didn't want everybody driving so
there was a drunk bus that if you didn't
get a ride home they would go around a
bar after bar and we would go on that
drunk bus and it was the easiest place
to hook up because we're all drunk you
got the the young gal who lost their
friends i lost my friends they were like
oh where bar were you at oh yeah and
then two minutes later you're like
happened every time it was super easy
and you just get off at her place and uh
that's how i met my wife
how i met your mother the theme song
this place
but there's something about your father
oh yeah oh my god it looks like dog [ __ ]
i know who says hollywood's out of ideas
like how i met your mother we flip it
that's it
spider-man 19. who cares i got an idea
spider woman
anybody spider woman i guarantee it's
coming i guarantee it but they're gonna
try to mix it up and be like she's a
she's a beetle go the other way friends
enemies book it yes that's the show
enemies is coming out
that'd be a better show maybe it would
be better it's all rappaport
what about uh what else what about their
shows we just do uh let's see save by
the bell
taxi uber yeah there you go
uh
family doesn't matter
just some mob boss that gets
cursed by his own son
hey hey we might be drunk is brought to
you by sheath underwear i i won't even
look i bet i'm wearing them right now oh
there they are i'm not i'm not today but
i usually am he usually is i can vouch
i've seen his [ __ ] the official two
pouch underwear of comedy fans
everywhere sheet underwear has been
cradling nuts and schlong since 2013 who
wrote this my aunt
[Laughter]
we love them you'll love them they got
it for men women it's the best they're
soft they're sexy they're slick they're
sleek you got the balls and the nuts
separated finally they need some meat
time plus that it's invented by a army
soldier and comedy superfan robert
patton he knew there had to be a better
way to unstuck the junk and sheet was
born futuristic dick pouch aside this
underwear is comfy cool and comes in so
many different patterns you can have a
sheath pair ready for any occasion and
they didn't leave out your lady drunks
either
the comfort you guys know for your balls
sheath has applied to boobs with the
sports bras tell them how to do it fatty
while we're drinking i might need one of
them
uh go to sheathunderwood.com and order
with promo code drunk to get 20 off your
first order and sheath 100 money-back
guarantee that sheath underwear dot com
promo code drunk
get sheath underwear and let them
support
your ball bag yeah what more do you need
wearing them right now
we might be drunk as excited to welcome
our new sponsor diet smoke
most of us have had a
i don't think this edible is working
moment then 10 minutes later you're on
the couch and you can't remember the
word cat i've been there
edibles can hit you when you least
expect it and their dosage can be very
uncertain that's why when we need the
perfect medium high we hit our friends
at diet smoke for the delicious delta 8
thc gummies
each gummi is infused with 10 milligrams
of delta 8 thc derived from american
grown health hemp delta 8 is simply a
slightly less potent thc the high you
get with diet smoke is somewhere between
the chilledness of cbd and that classic
stone feeling you get with regular weed
plus diet smoke comes in two delicious
favorite flavors blue raspberry and
watermelon i've been taking this stuff
to go to bed you know me i can't get
high i go inward i hug my knees i think
of my dad i cry
this stuff is top top-notch it's just
what i need it's like having a light
beer yeah i heard your dad does the same
thing he gets on his knees he thinks of
you he cries it's
this stuff right here that's how i got
in this mess mess
oh geez
it's legal in most states and
just check diet smokes website to see if
they ship to your state also their
gummies are low in sugar fat free and
delish so when cbd isn't enough and
traditional thc is too much enjoy the
smooth buzz of diet smoke that's
dietsmoke.com
use promotional code drunk for 20 off
your order that's dietsmoke.com promo
code drunk 20 off as a special offer
diet smokes coupon code can be used on
every order so give it a shot come back
say like yeah i'm doing this again 20
off again diet smokes delta 8 thc
gummies are not for use or sale to
people under the age of 21 please use
responsibly diet smoke isn't light
it's just right how i met your father is
the laziest reboot i was when i the
pardon me when i saw it got bad reviews
i was like good oh yeah oh yeah still
laziness what are we viewers doing who
are these reviewers how did they get
that gig
i guess you just i don't know because
now i guess like they don't really have
the power because i i care more about
the audience score for the most part i
agree although sometimes the audience
gets it wrong
true i i like some weird [ __ ] sometimes
but for sure like
i don't know like although i was i was
looking at branders the other day on
rotten tomatoes it's got like 65 percent
critical in like 89 audience i'm like oh
i'm with the audience yeah same i love
rounders i love that movie great movie
but yeah yeah like who are these critics
are how do they how do they get paid who
decides like you know your [ __ ]
it's not a great job anymore i hope it's
got to be a hard one good i feel like
they're worthless
i think the people can can review critic
uh going in for job uh job opportunity
the guy's like yeah well i found you to
be uh lazy wooden and not very good
review the critic
great show the critic the critic was
[ __ ] amazing so [ __ ] that
yes ahead of it's that was like the
cutaway before family guy yes yes
it every episodes on youtube the
creators
i believe it was and al gina mike reese
from the simpsons one of the best pilots
of all time oh really you can tell man a
good pilot
i gotta go back and watch that pilot
watch that [ __ ] what are the what other
peeves uh
[ __ ]
yeah you gotta peeve sally not yet the
wife bothering you
kids does she make you mad not enough to
kill
got the knife
that's that's the next episode we might
be drunk she she's dead and matt's like
you got to trust me it wasn't me who
stabbed her
you confessed last episode before you
did it i don't know what it is about my
lady but somehow she'll start she'll be
like and another thing and i'm like oh
and i'll pause the show and i want to
listen try to be respectful and you're
like oh yeah that makes sense [ __ ] that
[ __ ] i'm totally with you
all right i think she's done play
wait i wasn't done oh [ __ ] okay oh yeah
that's a good point you make a good
point there
play i'll tell you this thing you're
like come on get it
on one burst like you ever watching like
a youtube thing and and it's not synced
up properly that's his girlfriend
exactly she's she's going remember
yeah she's asian
it's kung fu
we're synced up i was watching that
jackie chan movie uh police story the
other day what the stunts are incredible
how'd that come up you're just watching
he's incredible dude i mean i'm a fan he
is
i mean he's incredible i was watching
like tarantino's favorite movies the
last i watched of the last uh 30 years
is top 20 and super cop the third one
was in it so i was like i'll watch all
three the third one well the third one's
apparently the craziest stunts i mean
the stunts are incredible the problem
with this movie is it's not good
like the the humor is just dog [ __ ] it's
weird as hell it's not good
jackie chan is
it's like a man on another level
incredible he's like a superhero and
he's so likable yeah you just love him
yes completely i saw an interview with
jackie chan once by the way he has to
come up with all these this is
choreography as well it's not just death
defying yeah he's the study coordinator
too yeah that guy's a beast hilarious
that he's like the way we work out jokes
he's like car lamp yeah backflip right
he's like a buster keaton almost he is
yeah but
i saw him on an interview once and they
were like how do you do this to your
body and he goes well who am i who the
[ __ ] am i you know i'm just a character
i'm an actor
i can i can sacrifice my body for some
good
movie and i remember being like what a
cool guy he's like willing to
i mean this is pushing for the movie
everybody else is like hey i'm a special
person i need uh i need bubble wrap he's
like nah nah who the [ __ ] am i i'm
nobody yeah my stuff going to get older
though because you see those outtakes
when he misses the stunt and you're like
that has got to hurt the next day but he
handles like a pro he's always giggling
he's always smiling there's a couple
where i think he's in the hospital
here's the clip of him drunk as [ __ ] at
some awards show i wonder
yeah it's pretty funny to see him drunk
as hell uh sally look up jackie chan
shit-faced
[Laughter]
now we're talking here's the jackie chan
gag reel
oh nice
everybody loves jackie chan he's so
lovable lovable
i want to see failed stunts that's what
i'm looking for all right so jackie chan
[ __ ] faced yeah yeah yeah jackie chan
shit-faced
maybe just drunk is a better thing i
don't know but it's it's yeah
it's funny to see like a an amazing
acrobatic guy just like yeah yeah
he's like if bruce lee maybe it got
scrubbed [ __ ] well you have to have
six movies called drunken master so it's
gonna be hard doesn't it drunk awards
show maybe there we go
now there's one of harrison ford drunk
at no warships oh really yeah yeah i
think we gotta this is gonna be like
this should be a celebrity drunk segment
we should be doing that's a great idea
drunken there's he's getting the the
nickelodeon award there or the mtv one
it's not up there you passed it already
what a what was it oscars was it emmy i
don't know he's pretty old it was a few
years ago
uh-huh
he looks pretty hammered there
until yeah maybe it's maybe it got
scrubbed i mean he's pretty good oh no
i wanted to see it is that it no this is
him
damn
oh i saw a leg break there oh my god
poor bastard
oh
face to face you ever clunk head
forehead with a friend that's the worst
feeling oh my god dude
no jesus christ oh that like snapped or
they look up look up harrison ford drunk
awards show there's some drugs
is he wearing the earring oh you better
believe it
that earring definitely hurts that's
when i lost all faith in in harrison
because because we're so into han solo
and indiana jones and then you see that
earring you're like oh come on dude
apparently he's a real dick at a like
comic-con because like indiana is like
it's fake you [ __ ] losers
get a get a life get laid go out and do
something get laid
i mean get off my plane is one of the
greatest like you can't tell me there's
a funnier like pure americana that was
like that was like when we respected the
office of the president in the 90s
you would never get a movie like that
now that was the 90s when no matter who
is president we're like we accept this
now both sides are like [ __ ] you yes but
the president is the hero can you
imagine that now like trump [ __ ] you
biden just like ah my [ __ ] neck yeah
he's like where are we who's playing is
this pull up the last scene get off my
plane uh it's one of the funniest action
scenes involved can we play this peters
or no
hold on one thing at a time where's the
drunk for i ever but it's not important
this is all right all right get off my
plane is big that's [ __ ] one of the
funniest scenes of all time i had this
movie on vhs air force one oh you better
believe it i think gary oldman was the
the lead russian bad guy william h
macy's in it oh yeah this is the last
scene
yeah this is back when the uh
the leader of the free world was still
when we respected her believed in him
like a president could actually do this
fist fight a guy
get off my plate
he's got to sit
by i broke his neck
the music too oh it's hilarious
that's perfect imagine jimmy carter
doing that
dude the peanut had a [ __ ] left hook
peanut maybe obama could you could swing
at a guy
yeah i don't know like that though yeah
obama's good at basketball he's like a
finesse guy he's not like a [ __ ] he's
not gonna do a slugfest maybe prime
mccain but he was never president oh
yeah yeah maybe bush he was a cokehead
bush jr he probably got a few bar fights
i don't know
he's a cheerleader wasn't he yeah
they're fit
[Laughter]
some terrorists come on he's doing
backflips
i mean this is this was bad yes
yes it was cool to see a president be
able to sink threes that was hot i got
wet on that what uh
that would be hilarious if they made air
force one but just like trump and
i don't know if biden would be funny
reason but it would be funnier
he's like [ __ ] please
everything he's like i'm scared
although trump being like an out of
shape badass would be pretty hilarious
it's like a golf beating the [ __ ] out of
people and then being like loser
[Laughter]
you could kind of redo that with a trump
type president if i'm elected i'll bring
back peanuts
[Laughter]
i do miss the peanuts
uh on the flights you miss the peanuts
you get almonds now yeah i like an
almond i'll take an almond over peanut
butter you know me i hate the bisque off
your biscoff hater and i hate a pretzel
my two biggest enemies are on the planet
you hate pretzels i hate a pretzel it's
just dried cardboard
carbohydrates with a couple of sprinkles
of salt on it yeah it's a good snack you
don't like a pretzel i like a pretzel uh
what how about being bamboozled well
give me a wreck all right now we're
talking
okay
hang tight here we go my nose went to
hell i got i'll give you a little all
right please pickles
oh i just had one the other day when or
when are pickles when are you not happy
to see a pickle that's a great i threw
some sliced pickles on my shawarma the
other day my chicken shawarma game
changer i throw some on a burger i'm
thrilled yes when are you not happy to
see a pickle
pickle even work their way into the
booze world with the pickle back yeah
pickles are [ __ ] good baby what's
your favorite episode of rick and morty
pickle rick
pickles are [ __ ] people love him love
a pickle he's got the jar outside even
sandler's going for it love it and they
got a pickling and a bloody mary pickles
are great love a pickle and a bloody
mary you know what they're good at
soaking up the booze a little bit
they're right also a term for being
drunk i'm pickled
pickled eggs yeah yeah any food pickled
any pickled vegetables damn good
yeah i agree sick greg i don't know what
that means i wrote that's your cat greg
right yeah i don't know what i wrote
wreck sick greg
huh your cat was sick no i wasn't even
sick i don't know what that's supposed
to mean something
damn sorry we can't crack this code mark
no i have no idea how about a scarf a
good scarf you ever throwing a good
scarf i'm not a scarf guy i'm not either
i saw a scarf on the tv like scarves you
know you know i if i'm gonna wear
something around my neck i get one of
those like uh you know things that just
go all the way down oh yeah
if it's that cold but i call that it's
kind of a name what does it think a neck
warmer
yeah it goes all the way over your head
and hits the neck i like those better
scarf i always lose clava bakla that's a
[ __ ] greek dessert that's what i'm
talking about
what do you what do you
zeliki's just looks like another
relative right now in the i know the
shirt
i don't know i'm sorry but i'm right
you're right no not that that's the one
with that overhead thing yeah no i just
like the thing that goes like just your
neck ah
a baklava baklava baka lava
i'm [ __ ] it up now
baklava okay
uh hold on i had a wreck oh i got it
turkey meat
hold on a turkey
straw
burger
my pickle wasn't a home run either but
no no pickles good oh hear me out here
don't get the ground beef get the turkey
meat i'm talking like you mix it up you
make i made turkey meatballs today
incredible turkey how do you how do you
prepare your turkey meat you just you
just make them you put them in the in
the skillet or the oven you don't season
it i'll season season little i put some
steak sauce i have with the steak
seasoning on there
all right but turkey meat is better than
beef he's michelle obama all of a sudden
he's trying to cure childhood obesity
kids get off the red meat turkey meat
i'm with you i try to go for the leaner
meat if it's available thank you
turkey meatball because we're so we're
married to ground beef but ground turkey
is is way better it tastes better to me
it tastes better it's leaner it goes
down easier meats the beef sits in you
yeah it's the after effect is better yes
it's like drinking a vodka soda versus
one of these right here right it's a
little bit of sugar in here yeah but uh
yeah turkey ground ground turkey
get on it that's good all right we've
turned it around a little bit i pulled
it i made it today so that's why i
pulled it out of my ass
i don't know what sick greg meant i
don't know either um now you got a bit i
got a bit idea hold on let me look at it
let's see what i got a little bit action
ground turkey get get on it folks
all right here's an idea
i saw uh
i saw it they're doing a documentary i
think it's on cbs about the holocaust
called undeniable
undeniable why are we even placating
these idiots
undeniably that's like if you made a
slavery doc like this was not at all
cool
don't try to tell me slavery was cool
that's undeniable undeniable damn
but that's not the main focus on this
like i guess they're trying to hit uh
non-believers
right
i don't know i mean why we why are you
even opening this up to discussion i
agreed it should just here's the
holocaust it was horrible let's watch it
not
they're focusing on uh
the the
the deniers
that denies a seat at the table that's
the problem what were the deny what
would the uh shutdown titles seriously
guys this did happen
[Laughter]
right yeah this is the real deal whether
you like it or not
this was a thing
this was a thing
it's just hilarious to like make it uh
to even include uh holocaust deniers in
your time to like be like guys it's not
deniable yeah
that is wacky yeah who did the marketing
there i don't know julianna margolie's
is like the host i think um
jewish
i don't think so is she i'll look i
think you'd get a jew to host well they
never do they never they never get jews
to play jews that's maybe she is i don't
know
i bet she's got something
hold on here she's a very attractive
lady who do you oh would i come on
let's see here we go
come on jew
i'm hoping for a jew
let's see i think i'm gonna go with mom
jewish
she's got the clavicles he's got the
shoulders just to new york
we're getting there
her mother
mother's all that matters here jewish i
knew it thank god her parents were both
jewish
immigrants from romania oh well that's
undeniable
what about the name though their name
feels margarites
or something italian or something
something's going on there
but yeah all right so she's a jew thank
god they got a jewish person to rep this
thing
but
yeah yeah you're right undeniable is a
crazy name you're right you're putting
them at the table you're putting them
with them you're bringing them in
i think there's something here
yeah yeah for sure
undeniable that's what you say about
lebron james you know like people always
say that you got to be undeniable yeah
you're going to be a comedian it'll be
undeniable
but yeah weird they say that about
six million
people getting
genocide
yeah i saw whoopi goldberg got in
trouble for that [ __ ] on the view what'd
she say she she whole thing was like
it's not about like racism right it's
it's not about she said it was white
people killing white people it's people
it's about like yeah it was like i was
you know the problem is what does that
matter you know the problem is people
are talking too much so
you get attention by being contrarian
and that's how these hosts
because i don't think she's anti-semitic
we'll be i mean i don't know her but i
don't i don't her last name is jewish
but uh and her first name is sex i think
she's probably oh yeah but
you know but i think people are just
talking too much yeah you're right as i
say as we get drunk on a three-hour
podcast
ground turkey
you gotta do it i think that's the
problem is like the need for content is
kind of overtaking common sense i think
you're completely right because at a
certain point you're like you do this
long enough you don't say something
crazy
that's the person i'm kind of worried
about aha well said
that might be the angle
whoopi's been around for [ __ ] ever i
know i know and and who made her in
charge she was just a comedian actress
and i don't think what she said was like
bigoted i think it's just incorrect yeah
yeah yeah i don't think it's like well
you gotta have an opinion on everything
and you can't go i don't know she's on
she's the host of a talk show it's
called the view it's not called the
truth right
the view yeah
so show i've never watched anyway i mean
it's like who cares what do you got for
well that's the beauty of podcast you
can go oh that's i don't know about that
and move on but they have to have
something to say they have to have a
sound bite what uh so i'm with you what
do you got all right this joke's gonna
get weird
but i'd like to try it out see what you
guys think here you just do it with a
holocaust denial right
i got some problems with it
um
this is a big idea here so bear with me
please this is a half baked
i'd love your input youtube peters
trying to wake you up all right
so i'm doing this whole thing on
immigration
and my grandparents are immigrants from
sicily and all they would do is talk
about how great america was i feel like
immigrants like america more than
natives like people born here we don't
give a [ __ ] we don't think about it
we're just born here we're spoiled we
don't know anything else yeah exactly so
they're like the freedom the opportunity
the american dream and i'm just like
where's uber eats
what's going on it's taking too long all
we do is the natives all we do is [ __ ]
because we've had it so good we're born
here they got here and they're like this
is amazing and it almost feels like when
i was a kid
my friend had this big house he was like
a spoiled kid and they adopted a kid
because if we have so much money we're
gonna adopt a kid and the adopted kid
was like an immigrant because he came
into the family and he was like this
house is incredible there's a fridge
full of food there's video game big tv
air conditioning and the other kid was
like i hate you mom
and that's what it felt like he was the
american well you the americans are he's
thinking about what he's losing the
immigrant thinking about all he's
gaining yes hey that's good
way to simplify and so
yadda yadda and eventually he was like i
need money dad am i and the guy's dad
was like why don't you go mow the lawn
and he's like i don't want to mow the
lawn and the adopt he was like i'll mow
the lawn and the uh the kid was like
these adopted kids are taking our jobs
you know that's kind of the the the
message there or the the symbolism
but it could be even funnier if he mows
the lawn and the adopted kid is way
better
because it's hard to complain about a
job that you turn down right yes it's
almost funnier if he like he doesn't
then the object he's like he's like oh
that's how you mow the lawn then he's
obviously like i'll try it and then he's
like he's [ __ ] taking our jobs right
that's funny yeah all right let's today
it's a big idea it's a it's a high
concept no i don't think i think it
works i think it's something funny there
for sure all right all right we're
taking our jobs they're taking our jobs
there's more there too i mean he's like
the idea of coming here and being
grateful i mean adopted is similar to
immigrants you're in a shitty foster
home you come into a real home real
family and
you know my my friend he was kind of a
[ __ ] he'd be like isn't mom annoying
he's like your mom's awesome what are
you talking about and he's like you
don't get it and he's like you don't get
it your mom's awesome and it's kind of
like america adopted is similar to you
know to immigrant
you know we're just like everyone's
racist we're all fat and and spoiled but
it's like yeah yeah you are maybe
but the adopted kid this kid was from
africa and he was like your mom's not
racist i'm here something there you
never hear kids sneaking out of uh
foster homes like where are you going
i'm looking for a better life something
like that oh yeah yeah
yeah i don't know like there's something
here though for sure something here
we've been drinking these pack a punch
by the way really strong i had this much
in it i'm like
dizzy well come on yeah it's really
strong you've been quiet
google [ __ ]
he gave himself that name i'm just
trying to call back to it i don't want
to be mean
but yeah all right all right these
adopted kids are taking our job what
else do you say about immigrants that's
like negative
they're dangerous yeah not me but i mean
that's what people that's what people
say but people are found on my phone
and
what yeah what else they don't
appreciate america or they come in
illegally this is a big one they're
illegals the main angle with the
adoption and
uh immigrant is that they're
they appreciate yes their new life more
yeah my grandparents would never shut up
about america they were like america's
amazing it's great you have no idea and
i was like all right whatever like can i
watch tv now because i was young you
know i didn't give a [ __ ] and that
really cemented in me how much they
loved it here oh think about what people
in other countries do to vote they're
going on like dirt roads they're doing
whatever they can here we're like uh the
election was today yeah yeah we can't
get that online yeah we can't get it
going on the internet we gotta go down
there and wait in line come on
yeah there is there is
maybe the adoptive thing is the angle
well it's like america people say we're
the best and it's like yeah we are but
when you're the best you raise a lot of
shitty people
yeah because there's a lot of people
that are like just used to the best yeah
right right yeah
and then the people who love america
are
they hate immigrants but like most
immigrants like phil hanley our friend
from
canada is technically an immigrant and
he had to pass all these tests he had to
pay a bunch of money he probably knows
more about america than we do
i don't know anything about the senate
you know i've barely voted i voted like
a couple times in my life you're right
they they do more
they have to prove how much they love
america to live here basically yeah get
a lawyer
paperwork that's the whole thing and
same with adopted we can just have a kid
we can just get we can have a kid on
accident
you know
by accident adopted kids have to or
people who want to adopt they got to do
all this [ __ ] background check [ __ ]
oh well how come that psycho can have a
kid on accident and we got to do all
this
it ain't right and ain't right
maybe that maybe i'll add that in
don't look at the screen i'm going to
ask you a question from this uh okay
this is a citizen test yeah this is good
don't do this no i want to i want to be
let's see
law of the land
see an immigrant has to take this test
uh the supreme law of the land don't
murder i don't [ __ ] know what is it
the constitution oh okay
now you know that was a layup i guess i
didn't get it i didn't get it but
yeah
what do we call the first ten amendments
to the constitution
ten commandments no
ten amendments this is what they're
supposed to like you not appreciating
being american
they have to take this test and we don't
so the bit has legs but it's uh
it's a lot to unpack it's the bill of
rights
oh my god how did we [ __ ] miss the
how are we missing these we both i blame
the negroni
[Laughter]
uh what is one right or freedom from the
first amendment
okay
there's four or five of them here right
to bear arms no it's the second that's
the same oh i think it's the first one
there are some things in the first
amendment you're given the
i think you said the first five is what
you said no oh it says there's five
speech religions oh
i think you said what are the first one
one of the first five i'm sorry my fault
we're about in 300. yeah i did say free
speech but all right keep going keep
going okay
uh what are two rights in the
declaration of independence
oh
say what you said bear arms
no this is different this is the
declaration these are not amendments so
oh you have the right to do this this
and this i just hope i see
the right to
[ __ ]
to make kids a family a job and start a
business
yeah
there's another one opportunity liberty
life liberty and happiness
okay okay we're getting there if we take
this test together mark and i are almost
a citizen yeah exactly that's what i'm
saying and they come here and they gotta
take this [ __ ] and then we give them
[ __ ] yeah
uh this is fascinating what stops one
branch of government
uh from becoming too powerful
insurrection no uh let's see uh
votes
a petition
we have a specific term for it it's
something and something oh uh [ __ ]
checks and balances yes sir yeah
thank you
uh who's in charge of the executive
branch
uh aoc no uh let's see who's in charge
of the executive branch
huh
man we are [ __ ] failing this is what
i'm saying
i'm gonna give you an easy one it's the
president
oh
get off my plane
i got off my website get off my pod all
right
all right so there's
should be a layup name your us
representative
our u.s representative yeah who
represents you
no i'm kidding
um in congress
our state representative i think it's
your local like
i think ours is jerry nadler
not with west side i don't even know
what that is geez i should know that i
don't know
that was the layout a lot of layup are
you [ __ ] kidding me way off from
malaya that was a threesome i thought we
were doing like a state representative
here yeah i was gonna say like kathy
huckle or whatever her name is my point
all right so that's it we asked these
immigrants to figure this [ __ ] out and
we're like but if we studied for this we
could do this that's true that's true
but you got like one right i know we're
[ __ ] like i got like two i'm like i
got the i'm like a nigerian i have no
idea that's not helpful
i'm i'm a polish guy
was that better
i'm basically a guy from another place
who's clueless and yet i live here and
was born here
that's all i'm saying i took a little
tip out of your playbook what do you do
well i uh you're gone for a lot of
february so i said well while you're
gone i'm taking the lady and going on a
vacation how how long you gone i'm just
gonna go three days something like that
three days
virgin islands wow
it's not a bad flight it's right there
newark direct only three days
four days sorry
but
short trip beach
uh b and b
the good stuff palm trees hammock
mai tai the whole thing
uh yeah what else uh what what gigs you
got mark oh yeah i'm in uh
let's see coming out this will be at
fort wayne indiana la jolla california
where are you playing it for rain uh
there's a new club called summit
it's the same guys you do tacoma
bricktown yeah they open a club there so
we'll give it a whirl i'm in
indianapolis i'm in addison texas i love
that room in dallas dallas by the way is
about to pass chicago as them as one of
the biggest cities people are loving
dallas dallas is nice i like it i like
dallas too [ __ ] kennedy
and uh yeah
i don't know if there's after i'm at
this might be after i'm at uh sacramento
so san diego orlando west palm columbus
uh you tell me i can't see that man so
we got uh what dating orlando on march
yeah salt lake city whatever the hell
that was before that oh yeah salt lake
city brea california uh beacon theater
new york city may 7th all this but you
can actually
12 yeah may 20th we got it now who can i
ask who's going do you have an opener
for a beacon
i i got people in mind all right all
right that's going to be a big get
are you doing new orleans
no oh i thought i saw new orleans there
i've been drinking but yeah i'm so glad
i've been doing these cities before you
why well i would hate to have to go out
there they've already seen you they're
not going to come see me well then what
they mean come see me then well they'll
see
oh you just said they're not gonna do it
the other way around what the hell well
i'm just saying i got lucky i'm i got
the
i got the the the prize first
uh you got sloppy seconds oh gosh whoa
dick down in dallas what the hell is on
your uh browser there sally play this
song play us out with dick down in
dallas oh please hit it well yeah yeah
mark normancom.com samrill.com check out
uh the rooftop special check out the
documentary i got this check out i got
this out the lunch sat in the city is
oh yes oh yeah yeah sat in the city
great number by the way
in the city and then uh what else uh
email us at we might be drunk pod at
gmail.com and uh what else uh we were
ahead that's the ladies we were at uh
risque business and
out to lunch sally you want to plug your
website no all right this is why you're
not getting any gigs
and yeah gotham studios okay dick down
in dallas
[Music]
what is this the guy you photographed
[Music]
the [ __ ] girlfriend getting [ __ ] by
a lot of different women we're both
going to dallas so are you there
[ __ ] [ __ ] in boston
[Music]
all right we love you guys and uh
yeah patreon.com
we might be drunk pod email so we might
be drunk pod at gmail.com new merch we
love you we got merch uh should i grab a
shirt grab a shirt we got these koozies
these are the hottest tickets in town
you want one of these when you're day
drinking female listeners there's only a
few more of these left so get on these
and uh
oh yeah and we have different designs we
have the rick and morty design we have
all kinds of stuff so uh yes true that's
sure check it out we might be drunk
pod.com to buy merch get get on it send
us some liquor send us some booze send
us some wrecks peeves
and uh drinks you you know what it is
thanks a lot we love you may we've been
drinking sunday's
[Music]
and i get down in the same way
up on the roof like a cob is coming and
naked samuel is feeling dangerous
i'm out to lunch here in new orleans
this woman doesn't look like i remember
her and i get down in the same way
we
might be
true
[Music]